the big thing that you always want to
ask when you're selling is intention why
do they want this what changes as a
result of this what can you not do now
that you would be able to do as a result
of this change who else in that in your
life would that affect why does that
matter if you can understand why
someone's there it's much easier to get
them to agree to getting them there but
if you don't know that someone's trying
to let's say replace their income versus
quit their job versus just have side
hustle money those are very different
intentions if I want to talk to side
hustle money I'm probably not going to
be like this is going to take a ton of
time